one last job I can do it who's the mark
the one responsible for it all the cults
the black magic this mark on my hand
we're gonna kill the black eye bastard
himself what you want to kill the
outsider you want to kill God tying up
loose ends in a series focus on
political intrigue and all things
metaphysical can't be easy and
dishonored death of the outsider a
standalone game capping off the story
from dishonour - it covers the exploits
of various sight characters on a more
personal quest that doesn't overstay its
welcome Arkane Studios continues its
tradition of coming up with an
incredibly inventive and cunning game
about elusive assassins making their
mark on the world around them while
choosing where and when to make the
tough choices my name is billy lurk
though there aren't many people who
remember for years i stayed hidden
captain of a ship called the dreadful
whale set several months after dishonor
to emily kaldwin and Corvo attano has
since left the Isle of carnico leaving
Billy lurk under the alias Megan foster
in dishonor - to return to her old ways
to track down her former mentor doubt
pulling from her skills working under
the master assassin they form a plan to
confront the outsider a deity of the
void roam an instigator of events
throughout the series Billy lurk will
use her newfound powers to sneak loot
and track down key targets to find a way
to eliminate the demigod once and for
all with no mark bestowed from the
outsider she is freed from the demigods
watchful gaze making the chaos system of
past games non-existent this serves to
set the tone for what players can expect
in death of the outsider where the moral
ambiguity of the story matches the
gameplay allowing her to go about
missions in different and inventive ways
often going for a more improvised style
that blends lethal and non-lethal moves
much like the previous games death of
the outsider makes effective use of
large open levels with each city block
holding a number of side events and
points of interest Billie's approach is
a bit different compared to the exploits
of Corvo Emily and doubt focusing more
on seeking justice for all that's
happened in her past her story aims to
round out the narrative presented in
both sonnet games but the general flow
feels lacking and somewhat unearned
while starting strong the story
eventually runs out of steam with its
final missions falling a bit flat with
that said there are many details packed
in for dishonored fans revealing
important notes that flesh out the
events since the last game every night
for weeks the same terrifying dream a
street fight my arm dead and lying in
the gutter my eye gouge doubt by a grand
guard sword but when I wake up they
still heard for hours gives me the
creeps
as an immersive sim each character and
object in the game space can be
manipulated opening up some rather
interesting gameplay opportunities like
baiting enemies with thrown bottles to
walk into traps for some rather creative
options like using the semblance power
to mimic the appearance of other
characters to get the jump on targets
the AI and dishonored is as sharp as
ever and will require some planning to
get through unscathed but if going in
full force is your thing then the game
won't discourage you with the more lacks
gameplay systems on display there's much
more incentive to experiment with the
tools at your disposal though Billy's
overall repertoire of skills are much
more lean compared to the other
characters while core row and Emily had
a sizable pool of powers the lone
assassin has just three along with the
side ability to wrap whisper where she
can hear the thoughts of nearby rodents
to learn clues and tidbits about
characters in the area focusing on the
key areas of traversal recon and
subterfuge her powers will cover the key
areas of what players will need
throughout their missions one power in
particular named foresight allows Billy
to project yourself as a specter to
scout and mark targets this skill is a
standout proving its usefulness time and
again when locating bone charms and key
items while the core gameplay systems
are razor-sharp the overall gameplay
potential can feel a bit limited
compared to the previous games creative
players will certainly make the best of
it though it's disappointing to see that
what you have at the beginning is
largely what you have by the end however
completing the game once will unlock the
original game plus mode replacing
Billy's original powers with blink
Domino and dark vision from dishonor to
bringing back old feelings from past
adventures in burials and Bank games is
the name from our cemeteries assignment
only taking seven hours to clear in the
normal setting
there are several locations that beg for
a return such as the mission to
infiltrate Karnataka's Bank leading to
one of the series most finely tuned
levels one feature brought in to add
more variety or the new contracts found
in the black market where you can also
buy items and upgrade your gear Billy
can take on a selection of side jobs
from the citizens in Kanaka ranging from
the bazaar such as killing an annoying
mime and making it look like an accident
to the more morbid like getting revenge
on a sadistic doctor who experiments on
his patients death of the outsider
channels much more of the spirit of
classic stealth action games giving room
to experiment and prod aspects of the
environment to see what works without
too many distractions from the story
along with a custom game mode allowing
you to tune enemy difficulty fail States
along with adding in a number of odd and
challenging options like Ironman mode
death of the outsider gives you a number
of ways to define the type of stealth
action game you want to play in a lot of
ways the more relaxed style does more to
complement the series is immersive sim
design compared to its predecessors kill
the outsider I trust you to finish this
I will doubt one way or another
dishonored death of the outsider is a
solid inventive yet somewhat subdued
capper to the stories from the previous
games while the smaller scope can be
felt throughout approach to allowing
players express themselves as a Master
Assassin is as strong as ever it's
uncertain where the series can go from
here but the standalone release proves
that dishonored is still a remarkably
designed at stealth action game with
much potential that offers players the
chance to be creative in ways they at
least expect
[Music]